this video is brought to you by
Squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the only one platform to
build a beautiful online presence and
run your business head to
squarespace.com for a free trial when
you're ready to launch go to Squarespace
calm /pi graphics and save 10% off your
first purchase of a website or domain
[Music]
ferdinand magellan was one of the
leading explorers of the Age of
Discovery often being cited as the first
man to circumnavigate the globe he
actually fell just short of that
milestone being hacked to death by the
natives on the Marianas Islands yet his
vision and tenacity despite tremendous
odds opens up the westward route to Asia
and established his legacy as one of
history's great adventurers in today's
by graphics we uncover the life and the
tragic death of Ferdinand Magellan
[Music]
Ferdinand Magellan was born around 1480
in the north of Portugal his family were
part Portuguese aristocracy his father
Creed Omega Hayes was an official in the
city of Xavier Oh while the family of
his mother Alden mesquita were
well-connected to the Portuguese rock
court both parents though they died when
Ferdinand was about 10 years of age and
he was taken into the rock court as a
pageboy Ferdinand was a page to Queen
Leonor wife of King John ii who reigns
from 1481 to 1495 he was then succeeded
by his brother King Manuel the first at
the beginning of the sixteenth century
just as Ferdinand was coming of age
Portugal was the most nautical advanced
country in Europe she had the best built
ships and the most experienced sailors
on the high seas these advances that
allowed the Portuguese to take the lead
in exploring the African west coast
however the Italian states had already
established land-based trade routes to
the east shutting Portugal out of this
lucrative market Portuguese businessman
and explorers sought ways to develop
their own route to the Far East that
would bypass the established land-based
route and so the rush was on to find a
seaborne route to the eastern markets
Portuguese explorer Vasco de Gama made a
huge breakthrough when he sailed down
the African coast and around the Cape of
Good Hope and then to the southern tip
of India over the ensuing decade
Portuguese established trade relations
with the Indian kingdoms during
Ferdinand's formative years exploration
and trade opportunities they were
constant topics of interest among the
Portuguese nobility the crown was fully
invested in this and they were prepared
to finance explorations around 1505
Ferdinand's now in his mid-20s enlisted
as a member of a 22 ship escort for
Francisco de Almeida
the first viceroy of portuguese india it
is also probable that he traveled to
such places like Malaysia and the
African territory of Mozambique in the
midst of this flourishing intercultural
trade he would have been exposed to a
dizzying array of cultures languages
foods and trade goods Magellan he
remained in the employ of the Portuguese
Navy for 80 years he was involved in a
number of battles the first being the
Battle of Cannon or in 1506 in this
encounter the Portuguese fleet of less
than 10 ships defeated in excess of more
than 200 much smaller Indian vessels
Magellan though he was wounded in this
encounter in February 1509 Magellan
participated in the Battle of day.you
against the Ottoman Turks in
southwestern India which was another
Portuguese victory a year later he was
present when the Indian city of Goa was
overrun having negated the Muslim push
into Asia the Portuguese turned their
attention to Malaysia in the city of
Malacca this island city was an
international port that served as a
gateway to the lucrative spice markets
to the south the Portuguese wanted
control over the city and they sent an
invasion force to achieve that in 1511
Magellan he was one of the invaders who
soon conquered the island towards the
end of 1511 Magellan was awarded for his
services with an award of riches from an
exploratory mission to the Spice Islands
of Indonesia he was also given a Malay
slave Hui named Enric a this man was to
act as a translator on Magellan's later
voyage to the Indian Ocean
[Music]
magellan he returned to Portugal in 1513
it spent eight years on the Seas of the
Indies he returned to a country that was
deeply involved both militarily and
commercially in the African continent
conflicts were ongoing with both North
African pirates and the Muslims who
inhabited the continent shortly after
returning to Portugal Magellan joins an
expedition against a revolt in the
Moroccan city of Azam or Morocco had
been a possession of the Portuguese
since 1486 as a result each of its
cities were obligated to pay an annual
tribute
however in 1513 the ruler of a Zamora
man by the name of mullah Zaman refused
to pay he then led a revolt against the
Portuguese with the goal of pushing the
invader out of his country the king
determined to put down the rebellion
with overwhelming force in order to
teach his subjects a lesson he sends an
army of 15,000 men under the leadership
of the Duke of Braganza this force that
soon quashed the uprising within a few
years however the Portuguese found that
the costs involved in keeping a Zamorin
order were more than the revenue
generated from the city and it was
abandoned during the Battle of asimov
Magellan he was thrown from his horse
receiving a leg wound that would leave
him with a limp for the remainder of his
life this was not the only unhappy
experience that he had in Morocco has a
prominent member of the victorious army
he was awarded some of the spoils of
victory but before long he was accused
of carrying on illegal trade with locals
by selling some of those spoils back to
the Moroccans at a profit the accusation
it was thoroughly investigated by
Magellan's military superiors and he was
found not guilty
still the episode it certainly left a
stain on his so far
exemplary record it seems to have lost
him considerable favour with the king
whose sister he had served as a pageboy
in his youth on his return to lisbon
Magellan requested an increase in his
pension on the strength of his service
in Morocco but this was denied by the
king when he requested permission to
accompany several other Portuguese
military expeditions Magellan he was
again turned down it was pretty apparent
to him that he'd lost the trust of the
Manik
with the king leaving him out in the
cold Magellan now set about formulating
plans for his own voyage of exploration
his intention was to find a faster route
to the Spice Islands by sailing west
across the Atlantic Ocean he was unaware
of the size of the Pacific Ocean or the
length of the South American continent
and so imagine that this would be
quicker and easier than sailing all the
way down to the southern tip of Africa
to get to the Indian Ocean
Magellan took his plan to the king
requesting financing for the expedition
he used the fact that the Spanish were
likely to reach the Spice Islands before
them and claimed jurisdiction over its
valuable spice trade as a bit of
leverage however King Manuel he was not
moved and he turned down Magellan's
request he did however give permission
to seek funding from other rulers
Magellan set his sights on the Spanish
crown as the backer for his expedition
he traveled to Seville where he met up
with other Portuguese Mariners and
navigators together they formed a plan
to take to the Spanish crown the
expedition would be presented as the
opportunity to achieve the westward
route to the Indies that Columbus had
failed to achieve in the 1490s there's
new routes it would also avoid
competition with the Portuguese who were
committed to they're well established
but much longer route through the Indian
Ocean as icing on the cake Magellan
contended that on the basis of his
cartography calculations the Spice
Islands would be found to lie within
territory that was in the possession of
the Spanish the proposal it was
attractive to the Spanish King Charles
the first
Magellan and his cartographer re faliero
when they joined captains of the
expedition
they were also made Knights of the order
of Santiago and given a 10-year monopoly
on all trade in the area through their
route along with 5% of all revenues
received from the route as a bonus they
would each be given a governorship on
the island the Spanish crown put up the
money for the purchase of ships and crew
and supplies this it was a stunning
success for Magellan yet despite the
financing and prospects conferred by the
king he soon ran into difficulties
Spanish sailors were incensed the two
portuguese mariners had been placed at
the head of the expedition when they
heard of all the lucrative benefits that
the two would receive they were angry as
still members of the Spanish courts
unable to stomach the Kings generosity
to these foreigners they attempted to
subvert the expedition the releasing of
funds was held up resulting in a flow-on
effect that made it virtually impossible
for the two captains to make the
preparations
mean working men while the first back in
Portugal
heard about the Spanish financing of the
voyage this apparently caused him to
feel regret that he had turned down the
request by Magellan he said about trying
to sabotage the Spanish expedition as
well sending an envoy to the Spanish
Court for that express purpose palms
developed - between Magellan and faliero
in fact the relationship between that
became so strained the faliero has his
captaincy revoked
indeed he was totally kicked off the
expedition more personnel problems
followed the Spanish prevented Magellan
from bringing Portuguese sailors on
board despite the fact that many of the
men that Magellan wanted were
experienced in sailing the parts of the
ocean that he was headed to in the ends
the majority of the creep was Spanish
although there was representation from a
number of other lands including North
Africa Magellan slave Enric a also
sailed with his master finally Magellan
had five ships ready to sail these were
the trinidad upon which he sailed the
Victoria the concepcin the Santo
Antonio and the Santiago in total there
were 273 men everything we know about
Magellan's voyage comes from the journal
that was kept by a crew member by the
name of Antonio Pigafetta they sailed
out of San Vil Harbor on San Lawrence
day or is the 10th 1519 during his time
in Seville Magellan had met and married
a teenage girl by the name of Beatriz
Barbosa who was the daughter of a
Portuguese friend not long thereafter
Beatriz gave birth to their first and
only child a son named Rodrigo when he
sailed out of Seville this was the last
time he would ever see them the fleet
sailed down the Guadalquivir River
finally on September the 20th they
headed out into the Atlantic Ocean the
first stop was Tenerife in the Canary
Islands getting there was plain sailing
but the next leg of the journey from
Tenerife Southwest across the equator
was beset by wild storms the chronicle
of Pigafetta describes many occasions
when the men thought that they were done
for his terrible storm winds battered
the ship he puts their deliverance down
to the divine inheritance of Saint
Anselm who showed his presence by a
light at the tip of the mast what he was
actually saying was Sint Elmo's fire an
electrical charge that is often seen on
the top of masts in thunderstorms
having navigated these stormy seas
Magellan set a course for Brazil which
was a possession of the Portuguese but
they had not yet established any
substantial settlements there Magellan's
five ships reached the Brazilian coast
November and then move south until they
reached the bay of rio de janeiro upon
reaching south american Magellan had to
face the reality of the geography that
had only previously guessed at he had
assured the spanish king that he would
discover a straight through this
continent that would allow them to pass
into the South Seas and then make a
direct runs the East Indies what he
found was that the South American coast
ran for far longer than it ever imagined
and there was no promise that he'd find
a strait to cut through it the
realization that they might be forced to
add an unknown length of time to their
journey by circumnavigating South
America caused tension among the crew
from Rio de Janeiro the fleet travelled
south to the Rio de la Plata estuary
that they stopped to allow the men to
explore inland here they came across a
tribe of natives described by Pigafetta
as cannibalistic giants
according to his journal accounts the
crew managed to coax four of the natives
aboard one of the ships while
distracting them with trinkets pick up
at her writes the captain had the
fetters but on the feet of both of them
and when they saw the ball to cross the
fetters being struck with a hammer two
rivets and prevent them from being opens
these Giants were afraid but the captain
made signs to them that they should
suspect nothing
nevertheless perceiving the trick that
had been played on them they began to
blow and foam at the mouth like bulls
loudly calling their devil to help them
Magellan put the other two in irons but
then decided to release them the actions
of the sailors appear excessively
aggressive towards the native people of
Rio de la Plata this led it to devolve
into outright combat Magellan lost his
first man when a sailor was hit in the
torso by a poisoned arrow Magellan he
made a speedy exit but rather than head
back out to the open seas it was decided
to head into the river in the belief
that it could just be the strait that
would allow them to cross the continent
it didn't take them long however to
realize that the waters they were
traveling in were freshwater and so
could not have come from the ocean on
the other side of the continent
when Magellan realized his mistake he
turned south coming to the port of San
Julian in Argentina just prior to Easter
of 15-20 he decided to lay up there over
the winter the rest would not be without
incidents a mutiny was incited by two
Spanish captains who had resented
serving under a Portuguese man from the
start
Magellan had the loyalty of the majority
of the men and the dissenters they were
sidelined and dismissed
during the layover the Santiago headed
off on a reconnaissance mission to the
south
it became shipwrecked in the Santa Cruz
River the ship was lost along
one of the crew members now just before
we continue with Magellan's journey let
me take a moment to tell you about
Squarespace who make these longer videos
possible
Squarespace empowers and that's the word
they use in their copy but I rather like
it it empowers dreams and makers and
doers it gives them the tools do you
bring their creative ideas to life
Squarespace makes it easy to their this
all-in-one platform so you can claim
your domain you can build your website
and then you can even do things like
sell online there's no fussing around
with you know getting a domain from one
side and then working out how to port it
over to the other website and then
working out if you want to how to sell
something on the Internet Squarespace
make this all very neat and tidy it's
all very nice plus it's not gonna look
too shabby either
and by that I mean it's gonna look great
they've got award-winning templates
which are an amazing starting point you
basically start with the template and
then you know tweak it customize it a
bit make it until it looks just how you
want it plus they've got 24/7 customer
support via chat or email and they've
also got loads of accessible not
confusing documentation on how to make
your website plus there's email
marketing built-in so you can reach your
fans and your customers look Squarespace
they make it easy so get that domain get
that site built get a shot up and
running if you want to just head to
Squarespace calm for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
Squarespace com forward slash bio
graphics to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain let's
get back to Magellan
Magellan was nailed down to four ships
after picking up the crew from the
Santiago they carried on down the South
American coast to Cape Verona's there
they found a straight between the
continents on mainland and the islands
of Tierra del Fuego
it was the strait they were looking
forward to take them across the far
ocean and would come to be known as the
Straits of Magellan one ship was sent
forth to see whether the saltwater would
turn to freshwater as they progress
through the Strait it didn't and the
entire fleet they had at inland before
long they came to a fork in the waters
Magellan cently concepcin and the Santo
Antonio were along the southeast Channel
while his ship the Trinidad and the
Victoria they headed Southwest during
this exploration many of the crew of the
Santo Antonio mutiny and the ship headed
back for Spain
the remaining three ships they figured
that the westward Channel was the one to
follow and so they headed down as on
November the 30th 1529 by December the
first they had made it to the South Sea
which Magellan rechristened the Pacific
Ocean getting through the Straits it was
an impressive feat of maritime skill
with many treacherous areas having been
navigated while Magellan was ecstatic to
have found the passage had been seeking
he was also very aware that he was
running desperately low on supplies
stopping to forage on the coast was an
option but this brought with it the risk
of further conflicts with the native
people as a result the decision was made
to push on directly into the ocean
despite the lack of food they had no
idea what they were in for it would be
another 12 weeks before land would be
sighted the food situation soon became
desperate with Pigafetta recording we
only ate old biscuit reduced to powder
and full of grubs and we drank water
that had turned yellow and smelled when
even the biscuits were gone they caught
and ate rats and then they were reduced
to chewing on leather cloth and sawdust
scurvy it became rampant and the death
toll began to mount among the first to
die with the two giants who had been
captured a few months earlier at least
thirty of the crew followed them finally
in January 1521 a group of uninhabited
small islands were sighted finding no
food there they pushed on until they
came to the island of Guam at the
beginning of March on this inhabited
islands they finally found food and
supplies from Guam the fleet headed
southwest of the Marianas Islands which
we know today as the Philippines
Gellin was keen to establish friendly
relationships with the native people
there thanks to the aid of his
translator Enrique he was able to
establish diplomatic relations through
the giving of gifts the demonstration of
arms and tours of his ships the people
of Limassol WA Islands on which the
fleet had landed encouraged them to move
on to what appeared to be the capital
island of Cebu this they did but unsure
of the reception they would receive
Magellan ordered the artillery to be
fired as they entered the port this
proved unnecessary as the people they
were friendly Magellan formed the
opinion that the chief of the islands
Rajah Humabon was the king of all the
surrounding islands so in securing this
friendship he imagines that he now had
the allegiance of all of the other
islands in this though he was mistaken
each island operated as an independent
sovereignty still Magellan headed for
the island of Mactan believing that
hereto he would get a positive welcome
however the chief of Mactan lapu-lapu
refused to submit to the strange
foreigners Magellan was offended and
withdrew back to Cebu there he prepared
his men to attack the inhabitants
possibly on the intelligence of Rajah
Humabon he was convinced that he would
not encounter a large force of resistors
he while he was wrong when Magellan and
his force of sixty men waded ashore on
Makaton they were confronted by between
1,500 and 3,000 warriors armed with
spears and arrows the sailors and the
benefits of muskets but these were
cumbersome slow to load and unreliable
hoping to cause confusion Magellan sent
some of his men to burn the hearts of
the natives
however they were soon intercepted and
killed Magellan's attacking forces they
were unable to gain any grounds being
forced to fight from the shore according
to Pigafetta the natives focus their
attention on Magellan the man who was
the leader of the invaders
he described the end of his captain as
such so many of them charged down on us
that they shot the captain through the
right leg with a poisoned arrow on that
account he ordered us to retire slowly
but the men took to flight except six to
eight of us who remained with the
captain the natives shot only at our
legs for the latter were bare and so
many were the Spears and stones that
they held at us that we could offer no
resistance the natives continued to
pursue us and picking up the same spear
four or six times held it us again and
again recognising the captain so many
turned upon
him that they knocked his helmet on his
head twice but he always stood firmly in
like a goodnight
an Indian held a bamboo spear into the
captain's face but the latter
immediately killed him with a lance
which he left in the Indians body then
trying to lay hand on sword he could
draw it out but half way because he had
been wounded in the arm with a bamboo
spear when the natives saw that they all
held themselves upon him one of them
wounded him in the left leg with a large
Cutlass that calls the captain to fall
face downward when they immediately
rushed upon him with iron and bamboo
spears and with their cutlasses until
they killed our mirror our light our
compass and our true guide when they
wounded him he turns back many times to
see whether we were all in the boats
thereupon
balding him dead we wounded retreated as
best we could to the boats which were
already pulling off the ship made a
speedy departure to Cebu only to find
that Rajah Humabon was no longer
friendly yet around 30 of the sailors
poisoned during a feast after that the
surviving men set sail for the Spice
Islands the goal of reaching those
islands it was finally met but Magellan
had paid the ultimate price in its
achievement more than 90% of his men had
also perished on the voyage the captains
of the two remaining ships disagreed
about the route home as a result they
parted ways with the Trinidad sailing
back across the Pacific while the
Victoria took the Portuguese route
around the Cape of Good Hope as it
turned out the Trinidad was stopped by
Portuguese officials with its crew being
arrested Victoria arrived back in
Seville Spain on September the 6th 1520
- the ship was laden down with spices
but the crew were near death from
starvation and the ship but it was about
to fall apart only 18 men were on board
from a total of 237 who had set sail
from that port 3 years earlier but those
eighteen men while they had the
distinction of being the first to
circumnavigate the globe so I really
hope you found this video interesting if
you did please do hit that thumbs up
button as always and also subscribe why
not Squarespace as well check those guys
out there's a link below and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]